[Music]
the purpose of my trip was to highlight
the positive attributes of Haiti and its
people but it's impossible to ignore
Haiti's ongoing crises as the poorest
country in the Western Hemisphere over
50% of Haitians live on less than $2 a
day and the countries plagued by a
stagnant economy government corruption
and a lack of healthcare clean water and
education add to that the many
misconceptions about Haiti that are
perpetuated by the media take crime for
example Haiti actually has one of the
lowest violent crime rates of any island
in the Caribbean yet in spite of all
these challenges resilient Haitians are
determined to lead their country into a
better future I met with a collective of
extraordinary expat business women who
have decided to return to their homeland
to kick-start the economic recovery of
Haiti I'm standing here with Paula and
Margaret and they're part of something
that's really incredible here in Haiti
you call it dot this is an initiative a
collective it's all women and women are
a huge part of the economic resurgence
for Haiti isn't that right absolutely
Haitians like to say that women carry
the country I have a 14 year old
daughter and every day she tells me
women in the future and I think actually
the future is now hi hi regine how are
you were you from I'm originally well
from Haiti but I I was born and raised
in Boston I moved back to Haiti when I
was 25 and what is it that you're making
here well is it
please tell me alcohol is involved
alcohol is definitely involved we
produce cocktails hot sauces iced teas
and cooking sauces
okay I'm gonna zero right in on the
cocktail on the cocktail just because
time is of the essence so this is a this
is lhara Haitian blackberries with the
grapefruit okay a little more
thank you now we're talking okay here we
go
that is really good I don't want to stop
drinking this I can give you more you
can have that you can now well you know
what you're doing you're enabling my
disease this thing is very energetic and
there's herbs and it what it does it
help men a couple women yeah what way
does it help men this is an aphrodisiac
I want that team now Gail tell me about
yourself were you from I am originally
from Haiti I was born here I actually
moved to the States
I went to Philadelphia University worked
at Goldman Sachs I worked at Vanguard
graduated from Harvard Business School
oh my god did a couple of businesses in
the States and always knew I wanted to
come home so basically we're the first
single serving prepackaged cornflakes in
Haiti well why do you think these are
better than the cornflakes we have in
the u.s. everyone tells me that's
actually true that's why we're gonna be
exporting I would eat this cereal every
night in my boxer shorts when watching
TV after my wife's gone to sleep that's
a description of our marriage in
dementia so buddy oils some of them are
fuzzy Zach oh you have an aphrodisiac
oil because I just had an aphrodisiac
tea I don't know if it's a coincidence
but you are in an all-female business
and I see a theme of aphrodisiacs for
men like you're trying to tell us we're
not measuring of it what we made is jury
for women I would wear that your work is
beautiful
Thanks I'm gonna walk out wearing this
and I won't pay for it because I'm a
very bad man I look fantastic in this
hat yeah this is a hat made in Haiti by
Haitians for a woman worn by a man who's
kind of womanish so we can I can show
you how somehow we work in the hub to
finish the product to get to the market
I can't believe your keep
a straight face while I wear this hat
and talk to you I want to thank you both
very much it's been an honor meeting you
and I just love the work you're doing in
the products great so I gotta go thanks
for the noise I don't know I wanted to
be here I know once I know I have this I
I have it I
okay just put that back up there that
was more your fault than mine okay and
then I'm just gonna get this frog booze
in the front no I'm good for more
information about dot go to facebook.com
slash dot 80 in addition to exporting
new products Teddy may soon unlock its
potential as a tourist destination
thanks to its natural beauty including
mountains waterfalls stunning beaches
historic forts museums artists colonies
and a thriving music scene and I too
decided to do my part to promote the
Haitian economy whenever I visit a new
country it's a little tradition I have I
like to promote the local beer it's kind
of a selfless act actually it's not
because I'm trying to get free beer and
the beer here is prestige regime you
work with prestige yes this is important
to the Haitian economy is it not
absolutely largest foreign direct
investment here in Haiti I want to help
Haiti as much as I can so I thought if
you don't mind I would shoot a quick
improvised commercial for prestige we
would love it and we start by toasting
man hey Conan O'Brien here when I'm in
Haiti and I'm hanging out with an
attractive woman who's pretending to
find me funny
I drink prestige beer it's the beer to
have in Haiti if it's not prestige then
shut up
I like that
Christine okay every drink yes
and then if you don't mind just turn to
camera and say he's hot he's hot sexy
and funny as hell not enough not any of
these
[Applause]
you